the desert road to bani walid is open
for the time being was down here that
the remnants of the Gadhafi army
traveled amongst them the colonel and
his son safe the military headquarters
nearby they're planning for assault on
bani walid if there's no resolution to
the current standoff military commanders
say that they're between 300 and
thousand Gadhafi soldiers in the town a
pro Gaddafi tribal stronghold but
they're being hemmed in from the north
east and west leaving a southern exit to
the desert we have no doubts that safe
Gaddafi is there and they want to shut
him up which a key didn't say that
nobody there's an escape and I said
because actually we are not sure but
safe I mean hundred percent is even we
need and we have to I mean shut up is
the speaker then yet speak again yet
NATO is now targeting pani will lead
from the air
the latest cockpit video showing attacks
on military compound and all heavy-duty
military machinery that's based there to
a degree the new Libyan army is happy to
allow the Gaddafi's to head south into
the desert to be picked off from above
but with such high value targets likely
to be in Valley will lead they're eager
to get inside and capture whoever they
can the military say that this road to
Bali Walid is being kept open for
civilian traffic with no checkpoint as
part of its negotiation with the tribal
leaders in the city to try and bring
this to a peaceful conclusion they say
there are 100 percent certain that safe
Gaddafi with three hundred fighters are
holed up in Benna Walid perhaps Colonel
Gaddafi but certainly his son and what's
left of the army appear to have few
options left a bolt into the desert
south their best bet but in reality with
every day that passes their chances of
escape get slimmer